EU economics and finance ministers are
set to approve recommendations on
national reform programs for member
countries in 2014 and on the economic
policies of the euro area the moves part
of the European semester process a cycle
that helps EU Member States balance
their budgets and improve their fiscal
and economic policies the council is
likely to approve draft recommendations
to help bolster the economic policies of
26 of the 28 EU countries and a specific
recommendation on the euro area these
recommendations will be forwarded to the
General Affairs Council with a view to
being endorsed by EU heads of state and
government on jun 26th and 27th the
ministers are also due to approve a
proposal to allow Lithuania to adopt the
euro as its currency from the first of
January next year which would make it
the 19th member of the group in other
items on the agenda the council will try
to agree a measure to counter the double
non taxation of corporate groups
deriving from hybrid loan arrangements
the aims to close a tax loophole that
allows companies to exploit mismatches
between national tax rules to avoid
paying taxes on some types of profits
distributed within the group